it's Steve Jobs Bill Gates
I've invited here today three industry
experts to have a panel discussion on
software and now ladies and gentlemen
the Macintosh software dating game
welcome to the Macintosh software dating
game software CEOs could I please ask
you to introduce yourselves hi Fred
Gibbons president of software publishing
corporation hi I'm Mitch Kapoor
president of Lotus we do a product
called one two three my name is Bill
Gates I'm chairman of Microsoft and
during 1984 Microsoft expects to get
half of its revenues from Macintosh
so software magnate number three when
was your first date with Macintosh we've
been working with the Mac for almost two
years now and we put some of our really
good people on it software CEO number
three
well Macintosh be the third industry
standard well to create a new standard
it takes something that's not just a
little bit different it takes something
that's really new and really captures
people's imagination and the Macintosh
of all the machines I've ever seen it is
the only one that meets that standard
software CEO number three describe your
ideal relationship with Apple
well we'll be selling our software
independently so the key thing is that
Apple gets a lot of consistent standard
machines out there quickly
well sorry Steve time's up we'd like to
give Steve a few moments to decide
today's winner
who's the winner apples are red IBM's
blue if Mac's going to be the third
milestone I need all of you
now I'd like to talk about meaningful
partners Apple lives in an ecosystem and
it needs help from other partners it
needs to help other partners and
relationships that that are destructive
don't help anybody in this industry as
it is today so during the last several
weeks we have looked at some of the
relationships and one has stood out as a
relationship that hasn't been going so
well but have the potential I think to
be great for both companies and I'd like
to announce one of our first
partnerships today a very very
meaningful one and that is one with
Microsoft
I'd like to take you through this the
discussions actually began because there
was some patent disputes and rather than
I know
rather than repeating history I'm
extremely proud of both companies that
they have resolved these differences in
a very very professional way we're going
to be working together on Microsoft
Office on Internet Explorer on Java and
I think that it's going to lead to a
very healthy relationship so it's a
package announcement today we're very
very happy about it we're very very
excited about it and I happen to have a
special guest with me today via
satellite downlink and if we could get
him up on a stage right now
work that I've done in my career and has
been the work that I've done with Steve
on the Macintosh whether it's the first
introduction or doing products like Mac
Excel these have been major milestones
and it's very exciting to renew our
commitment to the Macintosh we think
Apple makes a huge contribution of the
computer industry we think it's going to
be a lot of fun helping out and we look
forward to the feedback from all of
youse as we move forward doing more
Macintosh software Thanks
Thank You Phil you know where we are
right now is we're shepherding some of
the greatest assets in the computer
industries and if we want to move
forward it's the Apple healthy and
prospering again we have to let go of a
few things here we have to let go of
this notion that for Apple to win
Microsoft has to lose
embracing notion but for Apple to win
Apple has to do a really good job and
and if others are going to help us
that's great because we need all the
help we can get and if we screw up and
we don't do a good job it's not somebody
else's fault it's our fault so I think
that's a very important perspective I
think if we want Microsoft Office on the
Mac we better treat the company that
puts it out with a little bit of
gratitude
we'd like their software so
the era the era of of setting this up is
a competition between Apple and
Microsoft is over as far as I'm
concerned this is about getting a fat
healthy this is about Apple being able
to make incredibly great contributions
to the industry to get healthy and
prosper again
you know sometimes points of view can
really make you look at things
differently we here a new point of view
like for me when I was looking at the
statistics and it hit me that Apple is
the largest education company in the
world that was like a whole to lightning
that's huge
what an incredible base to build off of
another bolt of lightning is that Apple
Plus Microsoft equals 100% of the
desktop computer market and so
whatever Apple and Microsoft agree to do
it's a standard and I think that you
will be seeing us work with Microsoft
more because they're the only other
player in the desktop industry and I
think you'll be seeing Microsoft want to
work with Apple more because Apple is
the only other player in the desktop
industries so I hope we have even more
cooperation in the future because the
industry wants it
what you think each
is contributed to the computer and
technology industry starting with you
Steve for Bill and vice versa
um well you know Bill built the first
software company in the industry and I
think he built the first software
company before anybody really in our
industry knew what a software company
was except for these guys and that was
huge that was really huge and the
business model that they ended up
pursuing turned out to be the one that
worked really well you know for the
industry so I think but the biggest
thing was Bill was really focused on
software before almost anybody else had
a clue that it was really the software
that's well that's what I see I mean a
lot of other things you could say but
that's the high order bit and I think
building a company is really hard and
and it requires it requires your
greatest persuasive abilities to hire
the best people you can and keep them
keep them keep them at your company and
keep them working you know doing the
best work of their lives hopefully and
Bill's been able to stay with it for all
these years so bill how about the
contribution of Steve and Apple well
first I want to clip I am not fake Steve
Jobs
you know what Steve's done is quite
phenomenal you know if you look back to
1977 that Apple 2 computer the idea that
it would be a mass-market machine now
the bet that was made there by Apple
uniquely there were other people with
products but the idea that this could be
an incredible empowering phenomena Apple
pursued that dream you know then one of
the most fun things we did to go to the
mat was the Macintosh and that was so
risky and people may not remember that
Apple really bet the company Lisa hadn't
done that well and you know some people
were saying ok that general approach
wasn't good but the team that Steve
built even within the company to pursue
that even some days it felt a little
ahead of its time
I don't remember that twiggy disk drive
Andrew 28k yeah and AH the Twiggy disk
drive yes Steve gave a speech once which
is one of my favorites where he talked
about in a certain sense we build the
products that we want to use ourselves
and you know so he's really pursued that
with incredible taste and elegance that
has had a huge impact on the industry
and his ability to always come around
and figure out where that next bet
should be has been phenomenal you know
Apple literally was failing when Steve
went back and reenact a 'king that have
been phenomenal so the industry's
benefited immensely from his his work we
both been lucky to be part of it but you
know I'd say he's contributed as much as
anyone
most we will I some people here but I
don't think most people know that there
was actually a some Microsoft software
in that Apple 2 computer you want to
talk about what happened there how that
how that occurred
yeah the there'd been the Altair and a
few other companies actually about 24
that had done various machines but the
77 group included the pet trs-80 Amador
in the Commodore pet trs-80 in the Apple
2 the original Apple 2 basic the integer
basic we had nothing to do with but then
there was a floating point one where and
I mostly worked with walls on that I
made and we tell this story it was was
my partner we started out was guy who
Steve Wozniak brilliant brilliant guy he
writes this basic that is like the best
basic on the planet it does stuff that
no other basics ever done you don't have
to run it to find your error messages it
finds them when you type it in stuff
it's perfect in every way
except for one thing which is it's it's
just fixed point right it's not it's not
floating point and so we're getting a
lot of input that people want this basic
to be floating point and like we're
beggin laws please please make this
floating pose we how many people are an
app will me yeah the beggin laws to make
this floating point and he just never
does it you know when he wrote it by
hand on paper I mean you know he didn't
we he didn't have an assemble or
anything to write it with it was all
just written on paper he typing in he
just never got around to making a by any
point well this is one of the mysteries
of life I don't know but he never did
and so you know Microsoft had this very
popular really good floating-point basic
that we ended up going to them and
saying help and and how much was that I
think you were telling us her it was
$31,000 that Apple paid you for the
floating-point basic and I flew out to
Apple I spent two days there getting the
cassette the cassette tapes were the
main ways that people stored things at
the time I and that was fun after the
512 K Mac was done the product line just
didn't evolve as fast
Steve wasn't there as it needed to and
we were actually negotiate
a deal to invest and make some
commitments on things with Gil Amelio
and no seriously and we mean don't be
mean to him I'm sorry just saying the
words Gayle Emilio you can see uh and so
I was calling him up on the weekend and
all this stuff and next thing I knew
Steve called me up and said don't worry
about that negotiation with Gil Amelio
uh you can just talk to me now nice and
loud yo Gil was a nice guy but he had a
saying
he said Apple is like a ship with a hole
in the bottom leaking water and my job
is to get the ship pointed in the right
direction
okay
you approach the same opportunity so
very differently what did you learn
about running your own business that you
wish you had thought of sooner or
thought of first by watching the other
guy oh I'd give a lot to have Steve's
taste I mean he has natural not a joke
at all I think in terms of intuitive
taste both for people and products you
know we we sat in Mac product reviews
where there were questions about
software choices how things would be
done that i--dude is an engineering
question you know and and you know
that's just how my mind works and I'd
see Steve make the decision based on a
sense of people and product that it was
even hard for me to explain heat the way
he does things it's just different and
you know I think it's magical and in
that case Wow
you know because woz and I started the
company based on doing the whole banana
we weren't so good at partnering with
people and you know actually the funny
thing is Microsoft's one of the few
companies we were able to partner with
that actually worked for both companies
and we weren't so good at that as where
as where Bill and Microsoft were really
good at it because they didn't make the
whole thing in the early days and they
they they learned how to partner with
people really well and I think if Apple
could have had that a little more of
that in his DNA it would have served it
extremely well and and I don't think
Apple learned that until you know
several a few decades later
but you in that video we also you said
you had decided to that it was
destructive to have this competition
with Microsoft now obviously Apple was
in a lot of trouble and I presume that
there was some tactical or strategic
reason for that as well as just wanting
to be a nice guy right I mean you know
Apple was in very serious trouble and
what was really clear was that if the
game was a zero-sum game where for Apple
to win Microsoft had to lose then Apple
was going to lose but that's a lot of
people's heads were still in that place
why was that from your perspective well
a lot of people's heads were in that
place at Apple and and even in the
customer base because you know applet
invented a lot of this stuff and
Microsoft was being successful and Apple
wasn't and there was jealousy and this
and that there was just a lot of reasons
for it that don't matter
but the net result of it was was there
were too many people at Apple and in the
Apple ecosystem playing the game of for
Apple to win Microsoft has to lose and
it was clear that you didn't have to
play that game because Apple wasn't
gonna beat Microsoft Apple didn't have
to beat Microsoft Apple had to remember
who Apple was because it forgotten who
Apple was and so to me it was pretty
essential to break that paradigm and it
was it was also important that you know
Microsoft was was the biggest software
developer outside of Apple developing
for the Mac and na so you know that was
it was just crazy what was happening at
that time and Apple was very weak and so
I called bill up and we tried to patch
things up and since that time we've had
a team that's fairly dedicated to doing
the Mac applications and they've always
been treated kind of in a unique way so
that they can have a pretty special
relationship with Apple and that's
worked out very well in fact every
couple years or so there's been
something new that we've been able to do
on the Mac and a great great business
for us and and it's actually the
relationship between the Mac development
team at Microsoft and Apple is a great
relationship it's one of our best
developer relationships
so your question was about whether I
wish I didn't have to go into Apple
everyday no if you if you envy bill a
bit the second act that he has oh no I
think it's grilled see thing else I
think the world's a better place because
bill realized that his goal isn't to be
the richest guy in the cemetery right
that's a good thing and so he's doing a
lot of good with the money that he made
you know I'm sure bill was was like me
in this way I mean I grew up fairly
middle class lower middle class and and
and I never really cared much about
money and Apple was so successful early
on in life that I I was very lucky that
I didn't have to care about money then
and so I've been able to focus on work
and then later on my family and I sort
of look at us as to the luckiest guys in
the planet because we found what we
loved to do and we were at the right
place at the right time and we've gotten
to go to work every day with super
bright people for 30 years and and do
what we love doing
and so it's hard to be happier than that
you know that your family and that what
more can you ask for and so I don't
think about legacy much I just think
about being able to get up every day and
go in and hang around these great people
and hopefully create something that
other people will love as much as we do
and if we can do that that's that's
that's great
I mean you're obviously going to go down
in history history books already said
kind of thing but what's the greatest
misunderstanding between you in your
relationship and about each other what
would you say would be this idea of
catfight this idea of what which one of
the many we've kept our marriage secret
for over a decade now Canada that trip
to Canada
was there I don't think either of us
have anything to complain about in
general and I know that the the projects
like the Mac project you know was just
an incredible thing a fun thing where we
were taking a risk we did look a lot
younger in that video we did you look 12
and that's what I try and was 12 but no
it's been fun to work together I
actually kind of miss some of the people
aren't around anymore you know people
come and go in this industry it's nice
when somebody sticks around and they
have some context of all the things that
have worked and not worked and the
industry gets all we're all crazy about
some new thing you know like you know
the the there's always this paradigm of
the company that successful is going to
go away and stuff like that it's nice to
have people who've seen the waves and
waves of that and yet been willing when
it when it counted to take the risk
to bring in something new has it been
important to the one last question and
then we'll we'll go to the I didn't
answer this because he just said I don't
answer that is secret game okay yes I
thought that was your answer that that
wasn't my answer you know when Bill and
I first met each other and worked
together in the early days generally we
were both the youngest guys in the room
right individually or together I'm about
six months older than he is but roughly
the same age and now when we're working
at our respective companies I don't know
about you but I'm the oldest guy in the
room most of the time and that's why I
love being here
so happy to oblige happy to oblige and
uh you know I think of I think of most
things in life as either a Bob Dylan or
Beatles song but there's that that one
line and that one Beatle song you and I
have memories longer than the road that
stretches out ahead and that's that's
clearly true here at well you know what
I think we should end it there let's
just end it there I have another idea
thank you thank you very much
thank so much for lighting let us know
what you think in the comments below and
continue to